okay and welcome to a new duel comentary
game let's try to play a bit quicker I'm
going for a four I had successful d6 in
the last game so I try that again let's
see if he's coming up with something
different last time we played Knight f3
I think in this position wyd also with
course can exchange on e5 and DA 22 to
get an endgame gog three I could take
now play knight c6 to gain a temple yeah
should be ok often white can't allow
that because his copy should be five but
it doesn't look very logical after after
he's trying to check out the bishop so
now i can play G 60 B should be seven I
think g six loops it more active yeah
just complete development now h3 this
looks slow but certainly nothing I can
punish directly ok now black has some
pressure on the form looks like a pretty
normal position where black might it
might be a tempo up or something I try
rupee aids in order to play be five yeah
i prevented that now i could play a six
to insist on this move he might play a
five though I maybe I have a look a five
then which looks a bit strange but
I don't see how he covers upon then yeah
looks interesting at least but I need to
have rookie five otherwise that beer
positionally may be a stupid move yeah
it wouldn't be that bad but rookie five
really is the idea he could play night d
5 then but then I could could capture he
for I think don't think white has
anything special ya know would be the
time to to go for B 5 really maybe he's
got some strange ideas with e 5 then e 5
Bishop is a seven but this looks really
a bit strange now this must be must be
correct what I meant was i five the
night is saying so night xe5 and then
Bishop a seven which would would trap
the rook but I can't believe this really
yeah he didn't go for it so now I could
could simply take here and okay this one
is hanging so only other move would be
Bishop d7 but then he could take on b5
with some d4 Knight I think I have to
take this okay now maybe before I cannot
win a porn but
interesting yeah I need to play at least
a bit quicker and now c5 maybe with the
general exchange only six to come should
be out this structure only the six but I
got the good eye good I got the good
Bishop here might be too is hanging now
it doesn't really have any alternate if
he needs to take out at six now I think
could think about taking with a bishop
but keeping the night but this would
leave my bishop really strong this night
can be exchanged anyway all the time we
should be seven or anything yeah he
insists on keeping this piece yeah yeah
I don't have any problems but it's not
so easy to to make to make progress
maybe just take here and Bishop e7 there
should be at least comfortable equality
now I threaten ready to take here
because of the weakness on c3 yeah but
now though this is strange now he has to
take with the pawn this is just a good
position for black
if there's no strange trick or something
c3 is just just falling and it's not
just the pawn the problem is if this
pawn disappears it would actually would
be rather similar to pee on c4 then I
just have to take a guess yeah then I
get the i get d for for my bishop and
this is of course a fantastic square
with the idea to to get pressure on f2
especially okay he's attacking the six
maybe I just cover it for now okay let's
go pressure f2 this should actually
prevent him from moving the rook at all
at least I don't see it he cannot give
up the porn zone
yeah g3 was also hanging okay now to the
second rank prevent him from from moving
that rook now could also think about
Bishop b5 because this would be very
nice square yeah I need to speed up a
bit of course my usual slow self the
fantastic position though it really a
surprising years captured with a pawn
which gives me the eternal Bishop only
five that peace will never move again
but it doesn't need to only problem is
I've got 30 seconds
yeah bishop is six is really a bit
annoying don't see just 20 seconds what
else can I do
I could I could let him play it and just
claim it would bring oh is this a draw
already bruxism could be no yeah I just
need to get some quick Musa
yeah this was cost completely winning
for black but I was just just flown okay
I'm i need to stop the video to get the
second recording started